It's burning up, man. I guess it's only
me. Hey.
I don't know. It feels it's off.
Yes, perfect. Thank you.
[Silence]
Continuing in the lengthy narration of
[Arabic recitation]
recorded by Imam Muslim Rahim Allah
and this is known as the narration of a
new West
regarding the Dajjal. It's one of the
more detailed accounts and it also
puts a lot of the descriptions and
happenings of a Dajjal into
order. Put them into order.
We stopped off at the prophet
Ali was selling saying
[Arabic recitation]
Allah was selling that
this that jail this
liar this false Messiah is going to
emerge
from between and Iraq and Sham the area
of a Sham which we explained yesterday
and he is going to spread mischief and
he is going to spread discord
and chaos
and so the seeds of
disruption
to the right and to the left this this
statement to the right and to the left
meaning right and left everywhere right
when we say
you know this is happening right and
left meaning all over the place
all slaves of Allah be
firm be firm during that time
We said a messenger of Allah and how
long will he be upon the earth how long
will he reign for or how long will he be
here
[Silence]
said he will be here for 40 days
the first of those 40 days
will be equivalent to a full year
the second of those 40 days equivalent
to a month
the third of those 40 days equivalent to
a week and the remainder of his 40 days
will be
regular days equivalent to your average
day what What this tell us about at
Dajjal? There is some kind of
manipulation of time. Some kind of
manipulation
of perhaps the celestial
movements of
of the the the solar movements or the
lunar movements.
we're not sure exactly how this will
be.
But we know that it is meant to be
literal. It's not just that it will seem
to be.
It will be literal. Why do we know that
it is literal? Because of what comes
next.
But we also observe from this that he
will gradually lose power. He will
gradually lose that reign. Right? He
will start out as a year and then a
month and then a week and then the
remaining days will be equivalent to a
normal day, which means he will lose
complete control of this, whatever it is
that he will have.
And
this is the nature of falsehood.
Falsehood, when it first arrives, it
arrives big. It arrives incredible. And
the longer you spend with it, the more
you look at it, the more you investigate
it, the less substance it has. The more
the more cardboard it seems and puerile.
And so
we said the companions here are saying
and
So we said, "Our messenger of Allah, now
this this issue of the first day will be
equivalent to a year. The second day
will be equivalent to a month." This
could be taken literally,
right? And it could be taken
figuratively, that it will feel like
that, but it actually is not.
But we know that it is literal. Why?
Because the companions first understood
it to be literal, and so they asked a
question based on that understanding.
They said, "That first day that is
equivalent to a year, should we pray
only the prayer of a day?"
And he said, "No.
Rather, estimate
and pray the equivalents of an entire
year. If it were only seeming to be like
a day,
or excuse me, if it only was if it was
figurative and it only meant it
felt an an entire year, but it was
really only one day,
then
we would not be commanded to pray more
than five prayers, correct? Because five
prayers are not
obligated based on how we feel the
speed of time going.
Five prayers are obligated based on real
time.
And so when the prophet tells us
sallallahu alayhi wasallam oqdurou lahu
qadrahu,
that we are to estimate and we are to
divvy up that time and pray the prayer
of a year during that one day, we
understand that this means that it is
literal. The first day will be
equivalent to a year, the second day
will be equivalent to a month, the third
day equivalent to a week, and the
remaining days, how many days will that
be?
37?
Is it 37? The first day a year, the
second day
a month, the third day a week,
and then the remaining days. So, that
would be 37 regular days and three days
that are, you know, many days. So, 360,
roughly,
plus seven, so 367,
and plus 30, the highest estimate of So,
about 397
days at the beginning. Then after that,
it will
be regular days. This is something that
is incredibly haunting.
It's incredibly disturbing, actually,
because this will wreak havoc on the
earth. The entire
If you can imagine a year
in one day, because a day is governed by
the rising and setting of a sun.
Imagine the kind of chaos that will
occur on the earth.
And so,
after he said,
,
"Estimate an average and pray based on
that estimation."
When the hour has come, oh messenger of
Allah, and how will he be
in, you know, covering the earth?
,
how quickly will he spread and move
through the earth? Allah
said, "The day
is steadfast
and real."
He said, "He will be as swift and as
fast
as a strong rain driven by a strong
howling wind."
For the hour will come. They had to do
for you a minute
where you yes the day will be a little.
For the hour will come at the tomb of
Allah
for the tomb will be for the rule of
Allah for the day will come. Up
[Arabic recitation]
as he spreads through the earth, not
leaving any village or town except that
he will enter it,
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
says, "He will come upon a people, each
people of each town and each place, and
he will call them to adhere and follow
and pledge allegiance and
you know,
and and to
to be part of his movement and to
comply.
And if they respond in the positive
and they do respond to his calling and
they do believe in him, he will command
the sky and it will rain and he will
command the earth underneath them and it
will grow its crops.
And their livestock will
come home in the evening with
incredible amount of meat and fat on
their bones, their udders filled with
milk, their necks long.
He says, "And conversely,
[Silence]
He said, "And he will come upon another
people
and if they refuse his
dawah and his call and they reject his
movement, he will leave them. He will
just move on.
But the next morning when they awaken,
all of their wealth and property will be
in utter destruction and ruins.
He says
and he will come
upon a destroyed or
abandoned place of
you know, abandoned ghost towns and
places where people used to live.
And he will command these forgotten
and decrepit
lands and towns saying, "Bring forth all
of your riches and treasures."
He says
He said and when he commands
an abandoned
ruin
"Bring forth your riches to me."
All of its precious metals, its gold,
its silver, its diamonds, all of its
treasures will spring forth all the
buried treasures, all the forgotten
treasures, everything that that society
had to offer that remained in that place
will all come forth and beckon to his
call and he will move through the earth
with these precious metals following him
around swarms of bees.
This is for who? This is for his
followers.
He will
clothe them
in the finest of silk.
He will
adorn them and their women in the finest
of jewelry.
He will have all of the precious metals
and not just the precious metals used
for,
you know, used for adornment, but the
precious metals that are used for
technology. The precious metals that are
used for whatever the technology of that
time is. He will completely
consolidate all of the treasures of the
earth.
And so, people will see this.
People prone to vanity will see this.
People inclined
to luxury will see this.
And his followers will
be nothing but smiles and giggles.
Right?
And so, it will be very difficult for
people to
follow his call. And this is the first
mark of an empty call.
What does an empty call look like?
An empty call is one that you have to
give people
some incentive to follow.
You have to give them money. You have to
give them immediately something because
the actual call itself has no has no
substance to it.
Right?
Islam, the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam called the Muslimeen and they
came out of their riches into poverty to
follow him.
Exactly the opposite of the false
prophet.
The false prophet comes out and he
brings them out of poverty into wealth,
immediate wealth, not earned. They don't
have to earn this wealth.
As just just following and they are
given.
This articulates that it's a very empty
calling. The invitation itself is
very hollow. We will continue very
hollow. We will continue this